[Music]
hi my name is maddie i go by cafe maddie
on tik tok and instagram i love to cook
and share recipes today i want to share
with you some recipes you can try using
kimchi i'll be showing you three recipes
that are very very unconventional kimchi
is typically served as a side dish to
other entrees but it can also be used in
stews it can be used as a topping for
noodles for rice so it's very versatile
the first recipe i'll be sharing with
you is kimchi grilled cheese the first
time i had it was actually in amsterdam
when i was traveling i tried to recreate
it at home and it came out wonderfully
so every time i make grilled cheese i
never leave out the kimchi so i'm going
to
shred some sharp cheddar cheeps
i also have american cheese on the side
but you can really use any kind of
cheese that will melt on your toast
also i like to cut up the kimchi with
scissors in a bowl because if you cut up
kimchi on a cutting board it will stain
your cutting board i'm also buttering
both sides of my bread
to get started on the heated pan i'm
gonna put some olive oil
i like to cook my kimchi first on the
pan before putting it in the grilled
cheese because frying the kimchi will
bring out the garlicky flavors even more
i also like to add sugar to the kimchi
when cooking it because it'll balance
out the sour taste of the kimchi
when the kimchi is cooked set it aside
and then on a heated pan i'm gonna place
the buttered toast i toast both sides of
the bread because i like the crispy and
crunchy texture in the grilled cheese
plus the toasted side of the bread will
help melt the cheese even more i'm
adding the american cheese on one and
the cheddar cheese on the other one then
i'm adding the cooked kimchi add a
little bit more cheese on top because
there's no such thing as too much cheese
now that my cheese is all melted i'm
putting it together let it cook for a
couple more minutes to let the cheese
melt infuse
this looks about done so i'm just going
to take it off the heat
cut it in half and you're ready to eat
[Music]
i'm so good
so i feel like the kimchi is a nice
spice to the cheese it definitely cuts
through
the fattiness of the cheese makes me
nostalgic of traveling trying new things
discovering my own culture in different
places and then bringing it back home
never going back to regular grilled
cheese but if you're more in a snacking
mood the next recipe is just for you now
i'll show you how to make a kimchi spam
egg scramble this is a very nostalgic
dish for me because it's something my
dad used to make for me and my sister
when we were very little i like to cut
my spam up into small cubes so that they
crisp up nice and evenly
i'm adding three eggs into a bowl and
beating them until combined
on a heated pan i'm adding some oil
and then adding the spam
i'm letting it cook three to four
minutes or until they're crispy on all
sides
i'm lowering the heat to medium to low
and then i add the kimchi let the kimchi
cook for about two to three minutes
until it's fragrant once the kimchi is
cooked push everything to the side of
the pan add some butter
and then add the eggs
i like to cook my eggs on low heat and
very slow so that they become creamy and
custardy once the eggs are scrambled mix
it all together
and i like to serve it over rice with a
little bit of furry cupcake
so this is always like a comfort food so
good eggs are soft the spam is salty and
then the kimchi gives it a little kick i
can really eat this any time of day and
it really reminds me of my childhood so
this was a really simple and easy recipe
but if you really want to surprise
someone stick around for the last one
our last dish is creamy kimchi bacon
spaghetti i know it can sound a little
weird that's what i thought when i found
out about it through my college roommate
i thought it was really odd until i
tried it and it blew my mind so this is
definitely a game changer for you guys
and i'm so excited to share this recipe
i've cut up some bacon
i'm mincing the shallots and grating the
garlic
at this point i'm ready to start cooking
i'm boiling my spaghetti in salted water
and then straining it with a little bit
of pasta water saved on the side
on a pan of medium to high heat i'm
cooking my bacon until crispy this
should take about five to seven minutes
now discard all about one tablespoon of
the rendered bacon fat and then reduce
the heat to medium and add the shallots
to the pan i'm cooking the shallots
until softened for about three to five
minutes
and i'm adding garlic and kimchi
and sauteing until fragrant about 2
minutes
once that's done i'm adding butter and
heavy cream
season with salt and bring to a low
simmer once the sauce is bubbling i'm
adding the pasta and tossing it to
combine everything
i'm slowly adding the parmesan cheese a
little at a time and i'm stirring
constantly so the mixture is creamy and
nice
my sauce got a little bit too thick so i
added some pasta water to thin it out
and make it creamier and finally i'm
adding my bacon back to my pasta
to serve i'm topping it with even more
bacon and some scallions
i think this is my favorite from today i
know i ate a lot of kimchi today but i
can definitely keep eating this it's a
very surprisingly balanced taste so the
creaminess really balances out with the
sharpness of the kimchi so those were
the three recipes using kimchi in
surprising ways i hope you guys enjoyed
it we have the kimchi grilled cheese a
perfect twist to your normal grilled
cheese and then we have the kimchi spam
and egg scramble a perfect late night
snack and then last but not least we
have the creamy kimchi bacon spaghetti
which is definitely a showstopper pasta
dish you never knew you needed i'd love
to see how you guys use kimchi in your
own creative ways let me know in the
comments below you can follow me at
cafemaddie on tik tok or instagram and
until then i hope you try out the
recipes and enjoy
[Music]
you